grazie mille buon pomeriggio a tutti noi
siamo gli art penang punto arpa uno
strumento che ha delle connotazioni
storiche molto antiche quindi si parte
diciamo così dal lenticolo egizio egitto
e dall'antica grecia fino ad arrivare
appunto ai giorni d'oggi uno strumento
che è stato rielaborato ed è finito
nella sua forma nel nell'ottocento
abbiamo unito quindi queste sonorità di
uno strumento di una tradizione
millenaria all'ultimo strumento a
percussione acustica che è stata
inventata lang nel gennaio diciamo così
del 2000 a berna nasce questo strumento
che significa mano in dialetto bernese
sono molto famose o comunque nella zona
caraibica li steel drum che non sono
altro che dei bidoni per il trasporto
del petrolio che venivano suonati con
delle mazze molto grosse come se fossero
dei tamburi da questo strumento è nato
poi una rielaborazione appunto dell'ang
che si suona appunto con le mani le
nostre composizioni spazio né appunto
dalla dalla musica tribale e etica fino
ad arrivare alla musica contemporanea la
musica minimalista
un altro strumento che poi suonerò nel
prossimo brano è uno strumento che si
chiama di giri 2 è uno strumento
aborigeno quindi della zona del nord
dell'australia viene solitamente
ricavato da un tronco comunque un ramo
in eucalipto scavato all'interno delle
termiti
in questo caso è uno strumento in
vetroresina di fabbricazione italiana e
quindi si uniscono le nuove i nuovi
materiali quindi le nuove tecnologie
appunto per rielaborare a rivisitare gli
strumenti
diciamo così di un'epoca più passata per
rielaborarle per la musica più
contemporanea e non solo in quanto
questi strumenti sono molto ricchi di
armonici in modo particolare la rpa lang
e tanti altri strumenti le campane
tubolari le ciotole tibetani gondi tutti
questi strumenti che per quanto ci
riguarda
sfruttiamo nella sono terapia e nella
musicoterapia
ed è proprio su questo secondo argomento
che adesso accennerò qualche riflessione
semplicemente perché è una delle
direzione del nostro lavoro non soltanto
suonare ma anche capire quali sono gli
effetti della musica gli effetti del
suono sul interezza dell'essere umano e
quindi le ultime ricerche in
neuroscienze conservano quello che è
stato dimostrato nei tempi
dall'antichità da platone in avanti
anche forse prima anche nei vari popoli
nelle varie tradizioni popolari
abbiamo sempre creduto che la musica
potesse influenzare certamente l'essere
umano nel suo miglioramento e non sono
semplicemente influenza in che modo
quali sono i parametri che influenzano
l'essere umano allora abbiamo visto che
il ritmo la componente ritmica della
musica quindi la percussione in primo
luogo influenza certamente la parte
fisica il corpo e quindi dà luogo al
movimento ovviamente alla danza ma anche
al coordinamento alla capacità motoria
di sincronizzare le due parti
dell'essere umano quindi coordinare
nello spazio
abbiamo visto che la parte dell'armonia
dell'intenzione musicale e
dell'interpretazione quindi suonare i
forti e suonare piano il dinamismo
questo per influenzare la parte emotiva
della musica non gli devo spiegare una
canzone d'amore che tipo di emozione
d'amore nostalgico triste che tipo di
emozione ci porta noi ci siamo che
secchetti poi emozioni vogliamo portare
al nostro pubblico
sono emozioni nostalgiche sono in
mansioni di rancore di debolezza o sono
le emozioni di gioia di pace di
rinnovamento quindi ci sono tantissime
possibilità
infine un ultimo argomento che ci sembra
ancora più all'avanguardia oggi è
proprio lo studio che le neuroscienze
hanno fatto su il potere della musica
del suono in particolare di influenzare
le onde cerebrali quindi in qualche modo
di rallentare questo famoso flusso di
cui siamo sempre immersi ed è stato di
velia e quindi portarlo non stato un po
più lento rilassato che ci permette una
maggiore concentrazione per esempio una
maggiore memorizzazione dei dati che
dobbiamo accumulare nella giornata delle
nei mesi negli anni una maggior capacità
della gara di creatività anche di
intuizioni potremo dirlo così e quindi
il primo brano che vi abbiamo suonato si
chiama l'angolo del tempo è dedicato più
a questa parte e introspettiva invece il
secondo che faremo ora si chiama fest
cosa vuol dire festa della notte in
lingua bretone che una delle regioni
della della francia del nord della
francia di cui sono originaria e festosa
appunto si rifà alla tradizione celtica
grazie